foreign
[Music]
hey guys uh I will be in Pueblo Colorado
and uh uh whatever Colorado Colorado
Springs uh Colorado this weekend so come
on and check your boy out
um chrisley.com tickets and then I'll
also be in Las Vegas and Charlotte and
Nashville are coming up and Knoxville
some other ones but go to chrisley.com
to get tickets and also the new grow or
die merch and the pockets stay deep
merch got them right there chrisleya.com
we've got a little diving board on the
pocket there to let you know that your
pockets stayed deep uh but yeah and also
uh without further Ado let's get into
the next episode of congratulations
[Music]
oh man I was just on like a movie uh
trailer binge and just
just just just honestly
I think I'm good dude you know
people watching movies and [__] I'm good
I'll just watch the trailer honestly I
feel like it's just two movies are too
long now I guess sometimes the Netflix
ones or the stream ones are not long but
like you go to the theater Man movies in
the theater man
I mean sometimes these movies two and a
half hours
what what happens when you want to start
a movie at 11 o'clock at night you don't
put on the two and a half hour one
you put on the [__] uh one and a half
hour one so
you know I don't know I mean maybe
that's boring to talk about but it's
like at least it was quick right
at least it was quick that's my whole
point when someone's like oh you just
told a bad story I'm like yeah but it
was quick
the balls for a movie to be that long
period you know like I really want to
see Oppenheimer but you know
it's three plus hours right
I mean Christopher Nolan is great and
yeah if there's somebody's gonna do it
sure okay yes but how run time of
Oppenheimer
there we go three hours and he knew it
oh [__] dude he knew it not cause he's
psychic because people are predictable
right three hours and nine seconds knew
it was just just eeked it out over there
huh
dude I can't imagine could you imagine
like you know
and that movie's gonna make Bank too
Barbie's two hours you know
Barbie's two hours
like what make Barbie an hour
what the [__] do we have to see for two
at dads with their daughters in the
audience just like oh [__] man God
they don't even have genitalia what's
that nothing
that's so annoying
I don't get it man but Cillian Murphy is
a silly in her yes silly and he's really
good at acting oh Robert Downey Jr's in
it
that's cool and then Jack Quaid is in it
Dennis Quaid's uh daughter
I don't know maybe maybe it's a guy I
guess it's a son but I don't I just I
assume the other way now just to make
the left happy
um
yeah
oh dude you know what I dude Killian
it's Killian Murphy
whatever it is who you know
Killian's kind of a cool name
um
I have worked out and then I didn't work
out the last two days I've been working
out so hard where I go where where then
I feel sick afterwards and not like
nauseous like flu
and I'm like what is this so I Google it
I got fibromyalgia I don't but you know
it says hey you know what it definitely
is Fibromyalgia so I go I got
fibromyalgia so I go home and I say you
know what I'm going to do I'm going to
talk about it with
uh my wife she's gonna make me feel
better I text ah look what happened I
get you know how I've been getting flu
symptoms after I work out for three days
check that screenshot out sent it to
fibromyalgia with the it said
I get home because she doesn't respond
because Kristen is absolutely terrible
with her phone great
and I get home and I and she says so do
you really you think you got
fibromyalgia huh and I was like oh I
don't know and she's like oh I don't
know we should get it checked out and
I'm like oh great you're not even gonna
make me feel and it's like okay
so I said you really think I have it she
said I don't know I was like oh dude
you're not even doing the comforting
thing
so then I stopped I didn't stop working
out because I've been feeling
like that I stopped working out because
I had to go to Tucson the day on
Saturday then I came back on Sunday and
it was Father's Day
so I didn't work out Saturday and Sunday
and it's Monday now and I didn't work
out today yet
but
still started feeling like [__] at the
end of the day so it's not because we're
working out so I guess I don't have
fibromyalgia instead I just have a
permanent flu maybe I don't know
but um so now I'm like I'm pissed off
because this virus dude I had this
[__] it's been like two and a half
weeks Calvin got sick and then better
and then re-sick and then
it's you know having kids it's just like
everyone you're just gonna be sick all
the time
um
but so you know I've been trying to
pretend like I pretend when I'm dude are
you like me do you pretend deeply that
you're not sick when you're sick like
straight up you're like nah I don't I'm
good let's go let's go surfing let's go
just vomiting All Over The Ocean Spring
out the whole ocean dude um
but yeah so um
by the way how the [__] let me play that
actually
let me play that how the [__] is DJ
Khaled
how does he do it honestly and by it I
mean whatever it is he's doing how does
he do it
here we go
tell him to bring out the whole ocean
eating Seafood tell him to bring out the
whole ocean putting lime on it
or lemon
no not really it's eating
tell him to bring out the whole ocean
dude just not even like who's he with
so [__] him and Rick Ross dude the
loneliest guys in the world
tell him to bring out the whole ocean
Dude tell him to bring out the whole
ocean five shrimp is right there on it's
literally a plastic container of five
shrimp
and and two halves dude
tell him to bring out the whole ocean
not I mean a whole lotion is so much
bigger than that you know
man
he is so ridiculous
tell them to bring out the whole ocean I
was talking to my producer here one fire
and I was like bro imagine how annoying
it would be to hang out with him and he
said nah I'd love it and I said yeah
that for a night
imagine like you went at his house and
he was like I made the bed for you you
know there's another stay in one of my
rooms and you did and then you woke up
and then it was that again you'd be like
oh dude it's not time for this man
hello ocean just got breakfast come on
down we got breakfast
you want bacon you want eggs just you'd
be like oh relax dude
um
he is so lonely you know
uh uh I just don't know
I don't know about oh here's one of him
doing the breakfast okay
here we go with him doing breakfast
come on
this is called what that's just
it's called what and this is called what
I mean
perhaps what is this
water adding words dude that is the it
is so so Hood to add words that don't
need to be there and perhaps what is
this
[Music]
Sunday morning Sunday brunch
Sunday breakfast
so insecurity in there it's so lonely
this is called what that's just avocado
bro this is called what it's called an
English teacher and this is called what
an English teacher yes
this this is my favorite part right here
perhaps what is this
you know
it's water
giggling
so insecure at the end then ate the
whole [__] thing dude how is
he
man if I had a chef bro do you know how
ripped I'd be for I'd be craving the
hunter straight up they'd be like are
you craving the are you the real Craven
Hunter guy
um
and perhaps what is this she says water
I don't know how you oh God I wish I had
a chef I'm gonna get a chef when I
really be bowling I'm gonna get a chef
oh and I will get a chef dude
let's go to the beach I mean so let's go
swimming
oh let's go golfing I mean at the beach
I mean dude
let's go to the beach
at the beach let's go swimming
let's go golfing dude
wow
he's alone you know
like here let me just put it to you like
this dude
wow is he 45 I don't even know how old
he is but 40 45 imagine him 80 doing
this there you go that's it that's a
wrap oh he's crazy right you don't think
he's crazy because you think he's got
all his faculties but he's it's only
because he's 40 something dude imagine
the dude 80. gone you'd be like we
really gotta actually
we will got to start worrying about DJ
we really have to start worrying about
DJ
um
he's unreal
but uh yeah so I have been feeling like
I don't know what the [__] it's just
hanging on this virus but um
because it went away a little bit and
then it came back I went to the dentist
when it went away a little bit I [__]
hate getting I I hate I don't I like
going I'd rather go then to get my
haircut I just don't like going places
being at the dentist is fine it's cool
you just kind of open your mouth and let
them get in there you know you just kind
of let them get in there and you chill
and you just
you know I got a really I've got a
really nice dentist
and then a woman who cleans the the [__]
which is it's all a scam really because
here's why I'll tell you it's a scam I
said when's the last time I came here
and he said seven years and I said okay
my teeth feel fine he's like well let's
get in there gets in there he says man I
hate to say it but
for seven years I mean this is
absolutely fantastic do you keep up and
I was like yeah but like I don't you
know I brush my teeth twice a day that's
what I do I do when I wake up in the
morning and then I do it at night and
sometimes I do it in the middle of the
day do I floss no do I use a little hook
things that Kristen says I should use no
and they're in there just getting it you
know
and it feels good dude and it hurts but
it feels good you know and it's all too
loud and it's just
you know
and uh I got it done and I left and I
you know what I said to the lady doing
my teeth I said so what I gotta wait
like a half an hour to eat or something
and she says Ah now I can do whatever
you want and I was like yeah but they
make you wait like don't you have to
clean you know when you're a kid they
would tell you that she's like nah just
whatever I was like so I could drink
this coffee right now and she's like
yeah that's up to you and I was like so
they were just lying to us as kids
remember that [__] I don't believe
anything about time now when they say oh
you should remember when they would say
like oh dude you shouldn't go and swim
in it after you eat like what why why
what's gonna happen you're in water
it's not like the pool in involves just
getting a bunch of fingers poked in your
mouth and like just right
you're not swimming in in [__]
laxatives
you're just it's it's it's water it
doesn't who ate a sandwich and then
immediately jumped in the pool and you
oh I try it later I just eat and then
jump in dude it doesn't happen you're
fine you ever do the thing where you're
like uh let me just try it I'll eat yeah
[__] it I don't want to wait I'm just
gonna go in a pool and you're like it's
actually fine huh
I don't like that they lie to us dude
um
yeah so I went to the dentist they've
been lying to me for you you find it you
find these things out man it's like next
thing I'm gonna [__] I'm gonna find
out the Tooth Fairy isn't real
um
but yeah
I uh
I did I went to the dentist he cleaned
my teeth and then I go like this because
I have this Bottom Rung thing on on the
bottom there
and it was from when I had braces and I
was like dude can I get this all because
one night I was like I S I've had this
retainer in the back of my teeth it's
it's physically there I can't remove it
okay it's been there for uh
like
25 years right and
one night three two no two weeks ago I
was like man this [__] thing is still
here
like I've lived most of my life with
this [__] thing in my mouth that's
uncomfortable what if I'm in bed and I
can't sleep and I'm like what if
this is just like something that if I
remove it I'm like oh my God what how
have I been living like that
like
like we didn't know that uh when you you
know how you do circumcisions like oh my
[__] is I'm I'm snipped in the in the
front not like my vast difference I can
still have kids but you snip the tip and
you let the the flower come out
right and that's so that so the penis is
a turtleneck on just chilling right
like it looks like a pig in a blanket
and
I we didn't know until recently that
that actually makes it less sensitive
and it's oh it's y'all you're gonna ruin
the one of the greatest things busting
you're gonna ruin squirting
you're gonna ruin me spraying out ropey
barbells
huh
it's supposed to be the best thing
you're gonna make it a little bit worse
dude I want the best thing to be so the
best that when it happens I want to
think whoa I can't do that again for
days
my dogs are barking
pulse
so annoying dude
speaking of genitalia they don't even
have nuts you know like there's
hey shut up
stop
I [__] God hate uh we have four dogs
dude
you know we had I had two I fell in love
so okay another one because of love and
and then you know she had one and then
and then she had to [__] find one in
Panorama City dude
I wish you just kept driving
but now we have [__] trash dog
anyway dude what was I talking about
before penises
squirting was for squirting dude
the the [__]
dentist and the thing
so what if I
am like so I said this can I get it out
and he says wow and I'm like oh it's
another scam dude
nothing's even happening you know
they're barking sorry I had to cut for a
second because I had to go out and tell
him to stop I had to have a real sit
down with my dogs but um that's what DMX
says after a business meeting
um so uh so I said so I said can you can
you get it out can you get out the the
retainer and he says well
the thing is sometimes we remove it and
uh
uh and the teeth shift
and I'm like I've had this account for
25 years you don't think my teeth are
happy to where they are and he's like
yeah I mean it happens a lot you don't
know
so I'm like so what if you were movies
it could happen there's a chance it
could or you could just leave it and
then I'm back I'm thinking back to the
night where I couldn't I couldn't I was
I was basically having a panic attack
like I really worked myself up I'm like
there's a [__] something in my mouth
it's metal it's been there forever like
I'm just I can't sleep and then I dude
I've been having crazy sleep problems
for some reason crazy sleep problems
like where even honestly you know how I
talk about squirting helps dude it
didn't even help
like my legs are immune to the squirt
now
my restless leg syndrome has gotten
worse
so I'm like now I've got this thing in
my dude I gotta I've already gotta start
dealing with my anxiety a little bit
better but I have been because I go to a
lot of therapy you know anyway
um
so I let out I am like all right fine
we'll just leave it in if I need to take
it out I'll take it out because I don't
want my to come back and congratulations
my teeth are all [__] out to the side
like this like I don't remember what
they were when I was younger I guess
they fixed them but I still had this
[__] in
but anyway my whole thing is like
I don't know man I just
I don't know I'm okay though I'm happy
you know I finally got good sleep last
night dude
I took a [__] dude you know what
honestly I took us as
um I couldn't sleep the other night let
me play this voice message for you I
could not sleep the other night
and I was in
I was in Tucson
where is it
um
and I couldn't sleep and I was like dude
I'm not I'm not doing this
I'm not I'm not I'm not not sleeping in
another I don't even have like to wake
up for the kids or anything I'm just
gonna go to sleep in Tucson I'm asleep a
long time and I had NyQuil because I
still was kind of feeling like [__] it
was expired NyQuil and I was like hey is
it okay to take expired NyQuil to my
tour manager and also to my um
videographer and they were like yeah who
cares so I took it started to feel
really sleepy and then I was like let me
just top it off with a [__] like a
you know some kind of anxiety medication
because like I'm kind of like I'm on the
road a little bit anxious and [__]
dude so
I'm gonna put these dogs outside hold on
[Music]
talk about ship station let's take a
little bit of a break and oh right there
stop because this is important we live
in an increasingly automated world but
some things still require tedious manual
work now doesn't that yeah it's hard
it's it's rough on you right but look
e-commerce luckily for e-commerce
business owners shipping is no longer a
manual task and that's all thanks to
ship station stay save time automating
your shipping and returns into the
shipstation dashboard while keeping
costs down with industry-leading
discounts
for me running merch can be really
stressful no doubt but having ship
station in our corner it makes
everything easier with their dashboard I
mean I've done it dude if I've done it
uh trust me ship station is where it's
at ship station makes it easy to
automate uh shipping tasks for orders
um from every Marketplace in One
dashboard effortless integration
everywhere you sell online including
Amazon Etsy eBay Shopify and more
where else do you even go but more than
that okay manage every order from one
simple dashboard print shipping labels
easily compare rates and delivery times
to optimize every shipment and automate
delivery notifications and with
Enterprise solutions that make Warehouse
optimization easy shipstation scales
when you do
I spend more time growing your business
when you automate shipping tasks with
shipstation go to shipstation.com and
use code congrats today and sign up for
your free 60-day trial that's
shipstation.com code congrats
crazy crazy
all right we're back sorry I had to put
my dogs outside so I took the the
um
I took the uh
NyQuil and I started feeling really
tired and then I took the uh Xanax
because I was like dude I'm I'm not
I'm not [__] around I'm sleeping my
la Hey legs have at it is what I was
like gonna be like basically thinking
I keep sliding up this is great
um and so I played so I I ended up
taking it
and my legs were buzzing dude I could
not fall asleep and I got up and I sat
on the side of my bed and I talked I
start talking to myself and I'm so tired
right and I'm like man come on man you
got this dude come on legs I'm like you
you know let's get with it I need to
sleep I need I need this I'm not feeling
well I can't you can't keep me up
because my legs are dancing dude I'm in
bed I'm dancing and I'm like just I'm so
tired please legs come on Chris you can
do this that's what I'm saying and as
I'm talking
I'm I realize I'm I'm kind of
I don't know what I'm talking about like
I'm not just talking about my legs and
me going to sleep I start saying other
things now I don't remember what I was
saying because I was like half awake and
couldn't fall asleep
and then I was like wow I had to wear
with all to be like I don't know what
I'm saying I'm gonna send some voice
notes to my videographer and David
Sullivan so I sent three voice notes
to my friends
and then I forgot that I did that and
then the next morning
Sam is looking at me and laughing and
I'm like what's up and he was like dude
and I was I remember the voice I was
like oh I think voice notes right that
was you're laughing at it's like yup so
these are the voice notes that I sent
I just played the last one because that
was the one that was and this is not I
don't I I I do remember sending these
but I don't remember what they were
about this is I I remember now but the
next morning I did not remember so this
is what it was
the people
that don't care
I am man more I'm so
high if I'm being honest
from those
[__]
medication
and I keep waking up but it's all good
I can't stay awake
I'm not sleeping it's like I'm in a
world where the zombies are
quite
a live
what
oh my gosh
oh my God
I can't imagine again we're doing that
you know
[__] what
I mean dude like just so out of it
there's another one
I'll tell you more and more I think
about it
what I did was
I can't get what I want
yeah I know I'm just
wow dude I'm taking it
as it comes
said
absolutely nothing dude I love that [__]
I used to get that tired back when I was
uh
dating my ex-girlfriend and she revealed
to me a year later while we were still
going out she was like dude you know I
thought you had a pill problem and I was
like what this is back before I even
took any sort of medication for anxiety
I was like I've never taken a pill in my
life which was the truth and she was
like
uh really I I yeah I thought you had a
pill problem because the way you would
talk as you were falling asleep that's
what I would do I got I never started I
did that anymore
and then [__] bro I was so tossed off
of Nyquil
honestly the Xanax doesn't even I don't
even tell it I take such a low dose I
don't even tell anymore but I could bro
I don't know what's going on my sleep
it's just been so bad I'm getting old
dude maybe I can't eat late at night I
don't know what it is but bro I don't
want to give that up man that's like my
only [__] source of guilty pleasure
now it's just eating late at night
oh man
anyway I went to Tucson the tour reports
up go check it out on the other channel
Tucson is just
I love Phoenix man I really do I love
Phoenix and I love Arizona but also
what's Tucson you know like is it
just is it closer to Albuquerque Tucson
is Albuquerque basically
they've got those small Mexican houses
that are like turquoise and also beige
and a little bit like brown red
and it's like where they don't even have
Windows you know they have Windows but
like no glass over it it's just like
they're like yeah just don't Rob us dog
it's like the culture but it's all it's
also like have [__] indoor AC right
um but that was fun 1500 people came out
in Tucson loving it
um
and we just had a fantastic time dude I
saw the first episode of um Black Mirror
coming back and
um it was good the first half was so
good I loved how Netflix was like making
fun of itself with this thing stream
Berry the episode Black Mirror season
six count and then
um the the the second half of it it just
I mean dude it was so inside and so jerk
off Fest for Hollywood it was so bad
dude it was so [__] sucking bad I
couldn't even believe it and it was just
like Salma Hayek was in it and they were
trying to make her funny and it was just
like so written and it was just so
[__] bad dude I don't know how you
can make like here's the deal Black
Mirror Black Mirror was so good season
one season two and after that you can't
keep doing it you can't keep making good
shows
it can't last for more than like two
seasons because it's so hard to sustain
that world and and I know every episode
is different and every now and then they
do come out with a good one and you know
look God bless man you're gonna make a
good one you're gonna make a bad one
you're gonna that some of the best stuff
has also some of the worst stuff in it
because you need to take chances but
holy [__] man it's like you can't
keep making [__] that is going to be
such a great grand idea and then it's
all dependent on this twist at the end
to where this is why M Night Shyamalan
movies [__] suck now you know and I'm
not saying he doesn't make good movies
sometimes sometimes he does but like
when you're always waiting for this
[__] twist at the end it's like dude
and then the twist how many twists can
you make besides oh they they were dead
the whole time that's a great twist and
then the second one was oh he's a
superhero okay cool great twist and then
the third one is like oh they all live
in a village
or whatever the [__] that one was
oh nature is mad at Mark Wahlberg or
whatever the [__] that one was
you can't keep having twists
oh a water kills the aliens
that one sucked
oh dude it's water oh the thing that
sustained life for us is the thing that
kills dude Waters everywhere eh then how
could they we're made of water the
aliens are made of everything's water
and they're just walking around and they
find out because some [__] daughter
left a glass out that the alien can't
dude hey that movie sucks you can't rely
on this [__] this is why and I'll tell
you what I made [__] three four
specials that was a silly goose time and
that was by Design I never wanted to
[__] keep doing that but I was gonna
ride that [__] until I changed
my idea of what I thought was funny
until I change until I grew into
whatever I grew into you know how many
times can you [__] Rip Roar or a
silly goose time until you're the guy
who's like oh [__] you're 50. okay well
I'm 43 now dude the last special I did
that shit's not just a silly goose time
dude it's the best thing I've ever done
and you gotta change dude
once you get to know once you get once
you become something and people know you
as that guy you can't do that [__]
anymore
it's it's it sucks I mean I guess that's
where the money is but it's like dude
after I made fun of Eminem and I made it
in the video I'm done I'm done I'm not
doing it anymore
you know why because people want want me
to
I don't want to do what people I don't
want to do that
I don't want to do that I think that
there's a real thing actually that you
can like learn from this especially if
you're an Entertainer and [__] if you
become known for one thing you can't
you're a flash in a pan dude
and your boy's no flashing a pan man
not to say I'm not shyamalan's a flash
depending he's not he really is a great
director and I always watch his movies
but then like the island makes you old
or whatever like come on dude come on
man
it's not good just because you had the
guy for me too mama tambien in it
that movie was good movie dude hell yeah
I want to be in a [__] Spanish movie
like that and just be like
and then just [__] have one scene
where I kiss a dude wholeheartedly like
and just stroke them like and it shows
it but I'm not gay but in the character
is gay I guess but I'm not gay and I
walk offset and I go all right that's a
wrap
take that [__] rainbow flag down I'm
not with that so you can not you know
that that's what crystallia says and
they're like whoa that was but I'm like
but just so I don't I don't like that
[__]
that's how good of an actor I am I
stroked the dude and I'm against gays so
that's how that's how good of an actor I
am like Colin Farrell and the Penguin
Style [__] that's how I do it
it's cheating when you put that much
makeup on as an actor I think honestly I
think it's cheating
and I don't I love Colin Farrell I think
he's great
but if I'm gonna do
a movie
uh and they're like yeah you gotta play
a fat guy you know
like Brendan Fraser should have just
been like I'll just be this fat I'm kind
of fat anyway when he did the whale and
they're like we actually have really we
want to put a we want to make it really
fast we got a fat suit I I go you know
what I'm not doing it I'll just make let
me make the mummy nine
you know
um because I don't it's like you know
you get a [__] a beautiful woman and
then she does some movie where she plays
a mom and they put a hook nose on her
and it's like all of a sudden she's
nominated for an Oscar
and Colin Farrell's good but you you get
extra credit for that [__]
I don't I you know
and I know obviously I'm not there but
you know
I got offered a thing recently I'm not
I'm not I'll do it when I want dude how
about that I got offered a thing
recently in Hollywood I'll do it when I
want I don't want to do it now
so [__] these [__] that are
like ah yeah you know I'm oh dude
because when I do when I oh dude when I
do I'm [__] straight up ice in a
whole [__] cast goes gonna go like
this ow you know what dude he just play
my part too it's gonna be like the
clumps
just me in a drama though
um
Colin Farrell looks like the [__] in the
penguin huh he's good in that dude he's
good conference good he's too handsome
to be that good right same with uh
Christian Bale Christian Bale is top top
dog dude there's nobody who's a better
actor than Daniel Day-Lewis in the whole
world of anything that has ever happened
it's unbelievable I watched that [__]
tried to watch that movie fantastic
threat or whatever the [__] it is
Phantom thread
I mean just the the balls to make a
movie that boring for [__] sake and I
like boring movies I like movies that
you can kind of turn off and watch later
because you're not that hooked into it
dude the Phantom thread like this guy is
just sitting around talking to women and
like talking about making Fabric and
dude you expect me to watch this [__]
thing
I don't care how good of an actor he is
I don't care the guy can play a shoe and
I could believe it I don't care it's
boring
hey I'm a hot dog [__] problems
um but yeah dude I just uh
I I I just Phantom thread and I watched
it 25 minutes and I go like this all
right dude I
joke's on me I guess I I'm done oh you
won a catering award ah you know what
dude blow it out your [__] really
this [__] movie with zero colors in
it just tan beige and brownish and I
gotta watch and Danny De Luis is good
he's just like you know I make fabric
and when I make fabric and you don't
even know where the [__] Daniel
Day-Lewis comes from right that's how
good he is you don't know where he's
from you can be British he could be
South African he could be from [__]
Pluto you have no idea right
take my ears down they stick above my
head right like that could be makeup he
does because he's from Pluto because
he's got [__]
like when Daddy always comes into a
meeting you might be like I don't know
this is him he's just like
oh hey hi this is Daniel Day Lewis
yeah he's a translator oh well dada [__]
do you play all those other parts he's
just really good man but he's little and
green just pissing and [__]
everywhere oh my God can he just play a
character in this meeting
um but yeah dude I watch Phantom thread
and I am like all right he's so good but
who cares
you know
and that guy's a good filmmaker and I'm
the [__] don't don't get it twisted
I'm not saying you know people come at
me all the time you're like oh this guy
hates everything dude I'm I'm playing
I'm playing I'm playing it's all jokes
except for when I'm talking about trans
kidding it's all jokes always all jokes
sometimes it's not jokes but it's mostly
jokes
you know I'm in the middle dude I don't
the right and the left are gone to me
see ya see ya see ya see ya see ya
and I've made it how about this I've
here's the deal I've decided this and
I've decided recently Republican chicks
the hottest chicks period there I said
it dude oh he said it
too low
they are though they're the hottest
chicks and I was like why I started
think about this I'm like why are
Republican like women so gangster hot
you know and I'm just saying look and
dude you can't be mad at me you can't be
mad at me because it's just nature you
know what I'm saying but when I see a
republican woman and she's just you know
hey [__] off I mean you can't be too
right you can't be like I got my guns
here at Costco and [__] with a Q Anon
hat and just wait I'm look I'm out here
looking for [__] uh you know Robert
Kennedy or whatever the one that died is
that they think is the [__]
shapeshifter and at the parades now
what is it Robert
John Junior whatever it is you can't be
like that and then you're Bonkers but
dude a Republican and I'm like dude you
know why I think maybe Republican
because I was like what the [__] like
like liberal like way liberal it doesn't
matter how hot you are guys too I assume
I'm not attracted to men but like I it's
just such a turn off when it's like
and then I realized
oh dude
because Republican women straight up
have no
um and and they have no misgivings about
who they are you know what I'm saying
that's that's very attractive to me
right like you have no misgivings about
who you are you know who the [__] you
are you don't you're not like oh but you
know it's all you never know it's all
fluid and it could be tomorrow and you
know and and well maybe I'll cut my hair
here and do this and diet this way and
and wear this and I know but bro you
know who the [__] you are that's
gangster and that's hot and that's uh
that's what I came up with and that's
probably if I was still in Hollywood
that would get me [__] crazy
backlash but now it's just
also people are coming around you know
we're gonna look back I don't know how
long it's gonna take but we're gonna
look back on this section of time and I
don't know if it's gonna be the 10 years
or 20 years whatever the second of time
is and it's gonna be like wow man that
[__] was crazy dude
just as crazy as when like Woodstock
people were like just naked out in mud
just putting like like like pieces of
dirt like all in their anus and just
calling it free love you know
just chicks with their floppy sloppy
tits out you know just bad tits in 1970.
just with mud all over them and big
poofy hair everywhere
just listening to the doors I dude that
whole music I I don't I don't like I'm
not a music dude you know
I mean it really kind of does sound like
I Hate Everything But I don't but like
that whole music of the 70s like the
Steve Miller Band and [__] it always
sounded like any any genre of music
where it sounded like the recording so
far away from where the [__] they're
supposed to be recording you know what
I'm talking about you know what I mean
dude like now music's just like be on it
you know but back then it was like
foreign
that guy with that [__] instrument
that was just some guy in the back going
whoop whoop
whoop that though that music sucks dude
now we're all up in it sounds like the
music's inside your head man
music sure did suck back then people try
to tell me the Beatles are good and then
you're like all right play something we
all live in a yellow turn that off
thanks
people [__] say yeah well what about
Bob Marley oh well why because of the
political stance that he's uh oh yeah we
jamming we're jamming yeah we hopping in
the drama the law yeah all right dude
eat my [__] whole [__] man
that guy [__] um what's who's the guy
that got now there could be like nine
people but there's the rapper that's on
on on trial for murder ymh no no not
your mom's house why am why a guy
somebody who's
gonna
what is it
it's unwanted for killer and then
ynw
Nelly Melly
I mean so the name you know
just wanted for murder or I guess 24
years old and just like in in songs is
just like yeah I [__] kill a
[__] I did it it was on you know
it was on this street at that cross
street at this time it's like it's not
even rhyming he's just saying what he
did
and and they're using it against him and
then the prosecution just was like they
got the the DM from him and it was like
and he was like talking to somebody's
like yeah I did that you know how I
killed that guy and it's just like hey
guy all right dude
what are you doing man if you're gonna
kill someone shut up about it hey if
you're gonna do something like that
don't make a song about it huh
I don't know maybe he didn't do it I
have no idea
I always I'm a weirdo though man like
maybe I
um
it's so weird when people are like yeah
[__] it I hope he goes to jail [__]
and then it's also weird to be like free
him because like
you don't know but then also like I
always want it to work out because I
don't want to think that [__]
somebody killed someone
does that make me [__] naive I have
no idea dude
I hope that Melody
and W Melly didn't [__] shoot anybody
even though he made songs about it you
shouldn't be able to use rap or hip-hop
as proof though but I don't think you
can because it's a story you're telling
the story
foreign
be like if I made a song I don't like
when my wife argues with me it's so
[__] annoying when she makes me put
dishes in the dishwasher it's my only
chore but it's the worst one because you
get pasta on yeah
Chris do you hate when you have to put
the dishes into the dishwasher
ah no not really I don't do you hate
when your wife gets on you for that ah
no I don't what about when you uh get
pasta on your fingers no
okay see exhibit a I want to play the
song I hate my wife and when she does
this I don't though she's my angel you
know what I mean
I love
jokes are jokes you know but I really be
loving her
all right I had to put the dogs back out
again even though
please get them out dogs have more more
half better better have a better in a
house than me anyway
um
I saw this thing Bebe rexa Rex who I
don't even I'm I'm so out of it she's
probably super famous
singer obviously I guess she got man I
hate people someone threw a [__]
phone at her head you know
so loud so loud
oh [__] oh [__]
oh
that hurt God damn too if it man
if it was my phone it would hurt a lot
too because of [__] my eyes my
banking app in it and it makes my phone
heavier
um
just so she posted the pics dude she had
to get stitches
you can see the cut just above her eye
where she needed stitches and there's
significant bruising dude that's crazy
oh man [__] people who the who throws
their phone by the way
it was probably a guy who just found out
his girls cheating you know
oh seriously
this app
this singer was performing at the
Rooftop at Pier 17 in Manhattan as part
of her best
[__] night of my life tour
when somebody tossed the phone like
throw a bottle if you're gonna throw
some don't throw a bottle but like dude
that's your phone that's a thousand you
just threw a rack at her head
um
I hate that and then that one person who
did that ruined the whole show for
everybody you know dude I hate it
look at what an operation TMZ is they
have this and then they show it on TMZ
and then they get the video and then
they have another guy do you think the
person who threw a funnel Rex's head
during the concert should be sentenced
to jail let's let us know
it's like dude
the operation
and then they'll have they'll have a
poll and then the next be like do you
think that poll was right here it's
Frank at TMZ y'all think the poll is
right
[__] operation just keep on getting
clicks because some woman got [__]
smacked in the head with a goddamn
800 gig iPhone
um
and what about this dude
this is so sad Titanic tourists
submerged Titanic tourist submersible
goes missing with search underway here's
the thing about the Titanic if the
[__] Titanic couldn't do it
you know either you [__] five Rich
[__] are gonna be able to no my
heart goes out to him seriously I don't
mean to say [__] but
well I guess the Baby Rex hot guy got
arrested huh
um
here we go a massive search and rescue
operation is underway dude this is just
so awful when you're like
they got to be like we gotta go get the
we got to go search and rescue and
they're like we know
they're underwater they don't have okay
let's go it's so sad dude contact uh
massive search and rescue operation is
underway at the Mid-Atlantic after uh
imagine trying to find something in the
ocean dude you ever drop something
straight up like while you're sitting in
a chair where'd it go
it rolled where'd it go I didn't drop it
where it is how did that happen
it's so far whenever you drop some they
think they're gonna find this little
thing in the
tickets cost 250 thousand dollars for an
eight day trip including Dives to the
wreck at a depth of
wow this is horrible dude
um Ocean Gate is the for is the tour
firm
oh god dude they're done huh
Titanic's wreck lies some 435 miles
south of
and they wanted to look for it these
rich people
58 year old British billionaire
is among them
damn
on social media proud to finally
announce that he would be aboard the
mission to
see the wreck of the Titanic
um
but because of the worst winner in
Newfoundland Newfoundland in 40 years
this mission is likely to be the first
and only man mission to the Titanic in
2023 this is the thing man that's like
that [__]
God don't go if it's like well we can
but
look he later wrote a weather window has
opened and up and we're going to attempt
to dive tomorrow see now man who dude
you're going underwater
you're not going to the it's not like
well there's a lot of traffic
dude you're going to see
you're literally going to see a failure
and you're doing the thing that they
failed at
this guy wonton good soup tweeted I'm
gonna keep it real this is the most dead
anyone has ever been because they I know
they got to keep hope alive I know God
Twitter is just [__] awful you know
like families are grieving or like so
sad and worried and then good soup
goofball or whatever the [__] his name
is it's just like I'm Gonna Keep It Real
I'm Gonna Keep it a bean they died
um
look at this thing look how small and
cramped it is dude they didn't even die
comfortable too
so sad
they're so far from
I mean dude
this is so sad
not to end on a good note but
how about our Chris
how about how crazy that the [__]
Titanic is that's still look at that
that's still what a recently released
video showing a 3D video view of Titanic
shipwreck
wow there it is huh
doesn't even really look that bad
honestly
all right
look at that wow
oh this is not the real thing though
this is a 3D render I guess we can't see
under all that [__] maybe
how do they know that that's what it
looks like I don't like 3D renderings
they're not true man that's crazy
remember the movie Gideon uh where the
[__]
were the people the society is under
this they're in the ship
Gideons what's it called Mark Harmon's
in it it's where the [__] it's
beautiful dong thing happened
Mark Harmon Gideon Mark Harmon has 14
trillion dollars you know from uh
from uh what's that [__]
uh
NCIS Goliath awaits is what it is
Goliath awaits
dude let's watch that
I think I talked about this on this
practice a long time ago yeah I did but
Goliath awaits ending dude she says it's
beautiful and then the music hits so
hard immediately right after it's
beautiful
ending ending here
this movie was so bad
the whole movie is on it wow it's three
hours
eh
I don't
I mean don't make that movie
look at everything has an ending
explained I just wrote Goliath the
weights ending and then said explained
dude they just got out
um it's beautiful
you have it oh just text it to me
yeah
you have the actual hand wow it's
amazing
this is the whole movie
so I'll just go to the end of this then
just watch how hard the music kicks in
here we go
wow
[Music]
did you text me the whole movie
oh you did damn
I mean don't it's taking way too long
here we go
does that mean if I click on it
oh that means if I click on it it'll go
to it if you time stamp it really wow
let me just click that then that's crazy
that you can do that I don't know how to
do that
I did it no I got it I got it on the
text here we go
so quick dude
it's over dude I'd rather
me and my brother always talk about how
quick the ending is after that we saw it
why did we watch it why do you watch it
like that when you're a kid look at it
because it's beautiful
just
here we go again
over unbelievable they didn't give a
[__] about that movie you know
[Music]
wow that was a brown that was how we
turned it it's beautiful
[Laughter]
oh man that's [__] funny as [__] wow
how bad were movies but also good now
they're so bad dude I heard that in
Transformers or in uh past X the
Transformers coming at the end for real
that's just how it should be there you
go they did it they figured it out
finally now I like them I finally like
it
I finally like those movies all right
look you can get the grower die merch
you can get the pocket State deep merch
chrisley.com you can go come see me in
Knoxville come see me in uh uh
but Colorado I'll be there next week or
this week actually and then I'll be
there in a bunch I'll be uh where else
Vegas uh Charlotte
um in a bunch of different places so go
chrisley.com and uh appreciate you leave
a comment uh for me and uh make sure you
subscribed to this channel we love it uh
and then if you want to get the patreon
you get the patreon you get the unedited
uncut uh version of this show and every
show that ever comes out and then also
you get the uh extra episode a month
that we do uh here there's like 30 of
them maybe more at this point should go
get them now right now if you just go
sign up patreon.com chrislea I
appreciate you guys thanks
[Music]
thank you